bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques sur LCP Public Sénat
une heure en invité ce soir avec tout
André Chassaigne bonsoir à vous monsieur
le député merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle communément un pilier de
l'Assemblée depuis 2002 élus communiste
communiste du Puy-de-Dôme vous avez été
longtemps mère de saint-amandro
roche-savine sauveur vous avez été
conseiller général vous avez été
conseillé régional c'est-à-dire que vous
connaissez bien le terrain le contact
avec les Français on parlera tout à
l'heure des violences que subissent
effectivement aussi de plus en plus les
élus est-ce que les mesures prises par
le gouvernement vous semblent
appropriées vous présidez le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicain qui
regroupent les députés communistes et
outre-mer c'est bien cela on verra tout
à l'heure est-ce que vous êtes à l'aise
vous avec la Nupe on évoquera évidemment
les débats au sein de la nuque sur les
européennes sur l'avenir même de ce
groupe parle commentaires à propos de
d'assembler pareil vous avez des envies
d'aller au Sénat vous nous direz tout à
l'heure si c'est une rumeur fondée ou
pas avec Brigitte boucher et tamtrane
qui vont nous rejoindre tout à l'heure
évidemment on parlera immigration par
leur a aussi du budget militaire qui est
arrivé aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée on
parle du pouvoir d'achat Vincent roux
vous posera des questions d'actualité et
ifstréa encore une fois les questions
politiques un propos de politique petite
mise en bouche à propos du 8 juin qui
est quand même la grande affaire qui va
arriver à l'Assemblée le 8 juin cette
proposition de loi d'abrogation de la
réforme des retraites dont vous êtes un
des grands contenteurs vous êtes un
adversaire de cette réforme franchement
André Chassaigne puisque vous êtes un
habitué de l'assemblée
c'est un jeu de dupe cette affaire et
l'opposition et le gouvernement savent
que cette proposition de loi ne peut pas
aboutir oui mais je pense que le vote
s'il était positif si on a la discussion
ce qui est pas encore complètement
acquis ce vote répondra à une atteinte
populaire extrêmement forte parce qu'en
fait on n'a pas voté sur le projet de
loi il y a eu la motion de censure ça
porte sur l'article 7 c'est-à-dire sur
l'âge de départ à la retraite il y a une
atteinte extrêmement forte et il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle indemnité démocratie
dans la mesure où ce projet de loi n'a
pas abouti véritablement à un vote sur
son contenu là on pourrait avoir un vote
sur un article du projet de loi qui est
sans aucun doute l'article plus
important et c'est très attendu par les
organisations syndicales et puis il y a
un mécontentement terrible dans le pays
et je crois que c'est aussi une
dimension symbolique et ensuite sa
maîtrise le Sénat bien sûr face à ses
responsabilités donc vous n'êtes pas
dupe justement pour reprendre le mot du
fait que cette proposition de loignante
peut-être pas jusqu'au bout mais
symboliquement si l'assemblée la seule
assemblée votée contre vous diriez ce
serait important pour nous c'est
important pour les adversaires peu
importe ensuite disons que si
l'assemblée votée cette proposition de
loi pour supprimer cet article cet
article 7 c'est vrai que ça aurait un
impact considérable et je dirais que ça
alimenterait ça alimenterait le
mouvement social qui n'est pas terminé
on verra ça le 6 juin il y a une
manifestation on rappelle contre la
réforme des retraites mais quand même le
gouvernement Elisabeth borne a dit la
semaine dernière que cette proposition
emploi est inconstitutionnelle il n'est
pas possible de supprimer 15 à 18
milliards de recettes sans compenser par
quoi compensez-vous ces pertes de
recettes je dirais d'abord j'irai
d'abord
quels honte de tenir de tels propos on a
une fois par un groupe parlementaire on
a une journée qu'on appelle notre niche
parlementaire pas une fois pas une fois
une proposition de loi a été rejetée au
nom du soi-disant article 40 en disant
que ça crée des dépenses supplémentaires
mais y compris les députés de la
majorité actuelle ont déposé plusieurs
propositions de loi qui impliquaient une
des pinces moi-même lors du manque
d'après c'est d'ingérus à faire voter
l'augmentation des retraites agricoles
il est bien évidemment si on m'avait
opposé l'article 40 cette proposition
doit d'augmentation de retraite
agricoles il y en a même eu deux une
pour les chefs d'exploitation une pour
les conjoints collaborateurs conjoint
collaboratrice pour l'essentiel si on
m'avait opposé l'article 40 on n'aurait
pas dit je vous repose la question quand
même dans le texte quelles sont les
compensations financières à ces pertes
budgétaires
financières je précise que en début de
l'année on a voté un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dans
lequel il y avait pas la loi retraite il
y avait pas la retraite et c'était
équilibré donc les compensations
financières pour
comme dans toutes les propositions de
loi sont gagées par la taxe sur le tabac
comme dans toutes les propositions et
c'est ensuite au gouvernement de dégager
des recettes soyons précis parce que
vous savez quand il y a quand c'est fou
il y a un loup hein
la démocratie pour moi elle n'a pas de
loup alors elle n'a pas de loup là
démocratie
à quelques années ça ferait une
augmentation du tapas de combien si vous
êtes rigoureux et vous l'êtes André ça
c'est pas une argument c'est un artifice
c'est un artifice que la majorité c'est
de mettre dans les têtes moi je suis
pour la séparation des pouvoirs j'estime
qu'on peut au moins une fois dans
l'année porter des propositions de loi
et quand on gagne pas nous amuser avec
des artifices pour que la proposition de
l'homme n'arrive pas à en discussion il
y a une espèce de crainte mentale que
l'on met aujourd'hui dans la tête des
journalistes de crampes mentale en
disant en disant qu'il y a pas les
recettes et tout ça les recettes au
gouvernement des trouvées il fait
suffisamment de cadeaux suffisamment de
cadeaux au plus riche quand regarde
notamment le montant le dividendes dans
ce pays on aura les recettes on les
trouvera si à la volonté politique le
gouvernement avait le cerveau des
journalistes je dis qu'aujourd'hui
je le dis aujourd'hui on essaie de faire
monter cette idée que cette proposition
de loi ne s'inscrit pas dans la
Constitution qui a pas de recette je
m'en ce qui me concerne c'est pour la
séparation des pouvoirs une fois dans
l'année on peut porter des propositions
de loi et c'est un artifice
anti-démocratique de s'y opposé alors
c'est une honte à vous dire l'argument
du gouvernement va aller plus loin avec
vous pourrez chez boucher bonjour
soyez les bienvenus
vous dites que ce serait pas
démocratique finalement si s'il n'y
avait pas de débat sur cette proposition
de loi est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a peur du débat ou pire
peur du vote
je pense que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
il utilise une balance Roberval il
essaie de soupeser quel serait les
conséquences
du vote de cette proposition de loi et
quelle serait les conséquences de
s'arranger pour que ça arrive pas en
débat je crois que gouvernement
aujourd'hui à cette obsession que cette
proposition de loi ne soit pas votée
parce que ça alimentait le mouvance
sociale donc il met tout en œuvre tout
en œuvre pour que le débat n'arrive mais
ça veut dire que vous vous pensez que ce
texte peut être voté qui peut passer ici
à l'Assemblée nationale je pense que le
texte peut voter ne serait-ce que par
une décision
d'abstention collective par exemple des
républicains je pense qu'il a toutes les
chances de voter parce que s'il avait
aucune chance d'être voté est-ce que
vous pensez que le gouvernement sera
aussi fébrile que robergé s'exciterait
comme elle s'excite qu'on essaierai de
convaincre l'opinion publique ce que
cela n'a pas de sens qu'il y a pas les
recettes c'est bien qu'un risque réel
qui passe sinon il y aura pas il y
aurait pas de ce mouvement
bien sûr qu'elle s'excite
elle s'excite de façon phénoménale j'ai
vu à la dernière conférence des
présidents ou notamment elle a
d'ailleurs commis une erreur elle a dit
c'est du droit coutumier que l'on puisse
présenter des propositions de loi qui ne
soit pas soumise à l'article 40 or le
droit coutumier dans la hiérarchie des
valeurs je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est admis dans la mesure où
justement ces deux droites
Renaissance alors l'usage veut
d'ailleurs que le président de la
commission des finances statue sur cet
article 40 sur l'irrecevabilité d'un
texte est-ce que pour vous la majorité a
les moyens de contourner la décision
actuelle j'irai d'abord que la
recevabilité a été acté par le bureau de
fait puisque les deux représentants du
bureau qui sont chargés chaque semaine
de décider de la recevabilité de d'une
proposition de loi on dit qu'il y avait
la recevabilité il y a pas de problème
là-dessus ensuite il y a toujours
possibilité effectivement à n'importe
quel moment saisir mais c'est le
président de la commission des finances
c'est le rapporteur général moi je pense
c'est plutôt le président de la
commission des finances
le levier nécessaire pour que la
discussion n'est pas lieu je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont sortir du chapeau donc
éventuellement le débat pourrait ne pas
avoir lieu
j'espère que non alors j'espère qu'il
aura lieu
Coquerel et les filles qui est
effectivement présent la commission des
finances et que c'est un membre de la
majorité qui est rapporteur du projet de
loi voilà pour voir un petit peu
effectivement les enjeux
le président des commissions des
finances qui prenait la décision alors
on va se mettre dans l'hypothèse ou le
texte est bien débattu dans l'hémicycle
le groupe Renaissance est prêt à faire
de l'obstruction est-ce que c'est pas de
bonne guerre compte tenu de l'attitude
de la gauche pendant la discussion de la
réforme des retraites
je pense que faire de l'obstruction sur
un texte de la niche annuel d'un groupe
parlementaire
c'est pas très bien venu
dans le cas de la séparation des
pouvoirs
législatif qu'on dispose véritablement
en toute indépendance par rapport au
poids exécutif un groupe parlementaire
là une fois par an et c'est vrai que là
aussi il y a une forme de j'allais
presque dire aussi de droit coutumiers
que dans les niches parmentaires on
laisse on laisse du droit coutumier on
laisse
non pas tant que ça on laisse les
projets les propositions de leur
discussion ont aussi de on y a de
nombreux exemples y compris de c'est
extra ultra majoritaire en plus des
textes de loi Kanté y compris d'ailleurs
je crois pas européen on parle d'un
texte de loi sur le milieu vieillir qui
engendre qui a été voté et qui engendre
plusieurs milliards dépenses
supplémentaires il y a pas eu de
problème ma proposition de loi mes deux
propositions de loi lors du mandat
précédent sur les retraites agricoles et
bien
engendrer des dépenses qui étaient ici
mais deux propositions de loi certes
elles ont été réduites mais elles ont
été votées et le gouvernement a levé le
gage que qui a que j'avais mis dans la
proposition de loi je crois que je pense
je pense qu'on a écouté on a une
cinquième république Honda une
constitution
qui limite considérablement dans des cas
extrêmes le pouvoir législatif
aujourd'hui on a un pouvoir qui
n'utilise pas comme la Ferro car une
uniquement le 49-3 on a un pouvoir on a
un pouvoir oui c'est quand même plus
encadré on a aujourd'hui dans le cadre
dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites on a sur le même projet de loi
le choix du véhicule législatif
sociale le vote bloqué au Sénat le 49-3
et tout un tas d'artifices qui fait
qu'on cumule tout toujours pas qui est
véritablement revient débat législains à
cette proposition de la du 8 juin
admettons que le débat est donc bien
lieu est-ce que vous craignez qu'on
n'aille pas jusqu'au vote du fait et
bien de la mobilisation de renaissance
et de l'obstruction j'écoutais dimanche
le président du groupe horizon qui avait
l'air de dire qui mettrait tout en bas
pour pas oui pour pas pour pas arriver
pour pas arriver au ventre vous savez
dans la niche donc c'est possible
la gauche démocratique on a on avait un
texte
vous êtes l'obstruction a été faite par
des ministres c'est-à-dire que Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire
on parlait une heure environ pour
retarder les débats et faire en sorte
qu'on n'arrive pas à vendre
donc ça peut avoir
il montre depuis il manque qu'ils sont
capables de tout et quand il s'agit
dégrabouillés l'opposition et le pouvoir
législatif et ben ils sortent toutes les
armes qui peuvent trouver alors si c'est
voté en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale ce texte malgré tout malgré la
volonté des crabouiller qu'est-ce que
c'est changer est-ce que vous demandez
la suspension de la réforme des
retraites qui a été votée qui doit
s'appliquer au premier septembre la
suspension des décrets d'applications
qu'il y a eu dans le pays quand on voit
qu'il y a qu'il y a une opposition
ultra majoritaire dans le pays quand on
voit que les organisations syndicales
l'intersyndicale reste Unis continue à
manifester ça serait le cas le 6 juin
quand on voit que le mécontentement le
rejet de ce projet de loi reste entier
reste entier je crois avec un sacré
carburant
un sacré carburant qu'on mettra dans le
moteur pour continuer à se bagarrer
contre ce projet de loi demandé son
retrait et ensuite il partira au Sénat
bien évidemment le Sénat prendra ses
responsabilités je suis pas là la
réforme sera entrée en application le
1er septembre oui le temps que la niche
arrive au Sénat on sait que ça résume
très compliqué en plus d'avoir en
application effectivement on peut
toujours revenir sur la réforme sera
suspendue et qu'elle n'entre pas comme
le CPE
l'exigence que l'on peut avoir c'est que
si c'est voter à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est que le gouvernement est bien
suspendra cette réforme je crois que ça
serait la moindre des choses c'est que
le symbole sera tellement fort que ce
qui est manuel Macron a refusé depuis
des mois malgré 14 manifestations il le
ferait maintenant mais vous croyez
vraiment ce que c'est une question
moi j'ai pas baissé les armes je pense
qu'on peut encore obtenir le retrait de
cette réforme j'en suis persuadé mal
convaincu à votre honnête T20 vous
croyez vraiment ce que vous dites alors
par exemple avec les journalistes je ne
fais jamais de ouf avec journaliste car
je l'exprime j'exprime ce que je pense
ça fait depuis que je suis élu et ça
fait longtemps sans cumulent tout ça
doit faire plus d'un siècle un depuis
que je suis élu j'ai su réessayé de
m'exprimer en toute franchise je ne fais
pas de cinéma nature en à l'inverse
n'est pas voté est-ce que vous vous
admettez de rendre les armes est-ce que
vous dites voilà il faut clore cette
séquence des retraites ça ne passe pas
ici à l'Assemblée nationale contre moi
pour ma part je ne rends pas mes armes
ça sera déjà c'est vrai que ça sera un
signe si au niveau de l'expression
démocratique ça sera un signe si c'est
pas voté à l'Assemblée nationale mais
bon n'empêche qu'il peut y avoir des
textes qui sont votés à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui sont rejetés par le
pays ça restera rejeté par le pays on va
continuer à avancer
à continuer à faire passer d'autres
tests à éventuellement les voter on n'a
jamais dit qu'on ne discuterait pas des
textes qui peuvent être
discussion c'est à dire pour nous la
conception qu'on a de du travail
parlementaire de notre implication dans
un travail parlementaire même si on est
trahi ou si le peuple du moins est trahi
par rapport à ce qu'il atteint il est
bien évidemment qu'on va pas de notre
côté refuser tout débat sur les têtes
qui sont qui arrivent en Belgique
Laurent Berger a admis qui n'allait pas
faire des manifestations à répétition
est-ce que vous comprenez ce qu'il est
en train de tourner déjà la page des
retraites et de passer à autre chose
alors je ne porte jamais d'appréciation
sur ce que décide les organisations
syndicales jamais que ça soit des
agences syndicales à titre individuelles
comme c'est des propos qui ont été tenus
par Laurent Berger que ce soit l'Inter
syndicale j'ai dit que ça l'Inter
syndicale de prendre ses décisions c'est
à eux de décider des actions mais un
homme politique comme je le suis ne se
permettra pas de dire un dirigeant ou
l'Inter syndicale ont eu tort de tenir
tel ou tel point est-ce que vous êtes
sur cette ligne parce que c'est ce que
vous nous dites là vous ne n'écartez pas
de parler d'autres textes est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne chose
que Laurent Berger se dit on utilise
aujourd'hui et bien la force syndicale
qui a été rassemblée pour parler aussi
des autres sujets
ce qui ressorti des rencontres quand
Elisabeth borne les horlogs
j'ai pas vu dans les déclarations même
en décortiquant en faisant un peu de
sémantique j'ai pas vu des déclarations
qui consistent à dire en passant coup
d'éponge on passe à autre chose je crois
que les autres sujets augmentation de
salaire
que si on parle des sujets et je crois
que ça a été le cas que Élisabeth borne
et qu'Elisabeth borne dit que tous ces
sujets là ils sont renvoyés
à des discussions entre le patron dans
les organisations syndicales c'est pas
le gouvernement en tant que tel qui est
impliqué
du gouvernement aujourd'hui de un peu de
se laver les mains et de renvoyer aux
discussions avec le patronat c'est
ressorti des discussions des rencontres
il y a eu avec Elizabeth borne c'était
dans les comptes-rendus des
organisations
de la CGT Sophie Binet est-ce que vous
vous sentez aujourd'hui plus proche vous
comme communiste de la ligne Binet par
exemple que des lignes qui a pu avoir
par le passé il n'y a c'est offensive
celle de Sophie Binet je pense j'ai
jamais mis là aussi c'est une règle de
base
effectivement de la CGT même si on a des
amis qui peuvent avoir des
responsabilités dans certaines
fédérations avec qui on peut avoir des
atomes un peu plus crochus avec lesquels
on travaille davantage au niveau par
exemple des textes parlementaires mais
là aussi je crois que
le député chaque groupe comme je
jamais de porter une appréciation sur le
choix qui a été fait par un syndicat
quant à ses dirigeants c'est clair et la
je ne la connais pas les premières
interventions qu'elle a pu faire mon
plutôt séduit dans sa façon dans sa
façon de faire mais j'ai pas
d'appréciation à apporter sur la ligne
celle de la CGR le pouvoir d'achat les
syndicats attendent de négocier un petit
peu de pouvoir d'achat en plus notamment
Bruno Le Maire a dit qu'il comprenait la
hausse des prix des produits
alimentaires le prix des pâtes notamment
en rappelant qu'il a une famine
nombreuse et quatre bouche à nourrir
est-ce que cette inflation alimentaire
vous admettez quelle touche tout le
monde
elle touche essentiellement les plus
démunis et je dirais que ce qu'il y a de
plus grave
c'est que cette inflation alimentaire
elle touche sur la qualité de la
consommation qu'on peut avoir et toutes
les études qui sont conduites
aujourd'hui montrent que pour les
personnes qui ont le plus de difficultés
qui manquent d'argent qui manque
d'argent pour consommer ces personnes là
se rabattent sur des produits de bas de
gamme et je pense qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde est-ce que ça touche aussi Bruno
Le Maire peut être d'une autre manière
mais est-ce que ça touche tout le monde
légitime à dire ça non mais je pense que
non parce que faut quand même faut
considérer que des personnes qui ont
certains revenus ne sont pas touchés de
la même façon que ceux qui sont dans la
difficulté quotidienne dans la précarité
enfin je trouve que tenir ses propos
particulièrement
comme ça on regarde des revenus que je
peux avoir je trouve ça
un côté
côté hors sol je veux pas utiliser des
mots trop forts mais ça a un côté hors
sol j'arrive pas à comprendre que puisse
qu'on puisse tenir ses propos là parce
que c'est une forme de méconnaissance je
crois qu'il y a un décrochage de ceux
qui nous dirigent avec la réalité des
gens qui souffrent au quotidien alors
Bruno Le Maire a quand même annoncé la
prolongation du panier anti-inflation
qui va donc aller jusqu'au 15 septembre
est-ce que ça c'est un soulagement parce
que c'est quand même qui sont beaucoup
moins cher ok ok d'abord la grande
distribution chacun fait ce qu'il veut
faire avec des différences d'un magasin
à l'autre d'un hypermarché à l'autre un
supermarché à l'autre et pour ma part je
pense que tout ça c'est espèce de
discussion qui consiste à dire on va se
mettre d'accord je fais appel à vous
c'est exactement d'ailleurs sur sur
l'industri agroalimentaire c'est pareil
avec la grande distribution c'est dire
voilà soyez raisonnable baissez vos prix
moi je suis favorable à des mesures
beaucoup plus fortes
mais aussi des mesures beaucoup plus
contraignantes sur le coût des produits
il faut plus d'administration par
rapport à ça
laisse faire en quelque sorte moi je
suis pour être beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus coercitif parce que les mesures qui
sont prises telles que celles qui sont
prises aujourd'hui par la grande
distribution c'est des mesures
provisoires c'est des mesures qui qui se
font 5 contrôles qui se font sans
contrôle chacun fait ce qu'il veut et au
final c'est un peu la liberté de renard
libre dans le poulailleri un sujet qui a
beaucoup fait parler la semaine dernière
le l'audition du maire de Saint-Brévin
qui a livré un témoignage accablant sur
l'absence de réaction du préfet du
sous-préfet de Loire-Atlantique face aux
violences dont il faisait l'objet si le
témoignage est bien prouvé ce que pour
vous c'est haut fonctionnaire peuvent
encore rester en place
je sais pas exactement ce qui s'est
passé moi j'ai été maire pendant 27 ans
dans un petit village de 500 habitants
j'ai vécu aussi des moments extrêmement
difficiles j'avais dans mon village
pendant sa durée 13 ans un festival rock
avec des plus grands noms village 500
habitants avec Arnaud Baschung la mano
negraphe et j'en passe et c'est vrai que
un certain moment il y a eu un rejet de
la population par rapport par rapport à
ce qu'on faisait on a tenu le coup vous
avez été menacé
à l'époque c'était beaucoup il y avait
des une opposition moi j'aurai une tout
le monde dans la salle des fêtes j'ai
mis ça au carré quoi j'ai expliqué des
choses et au final nous-mêmes on a
évolué au final d'ailleurs on a arrêté
ce festivalent
il y a aujourd'hui tous les maires avec
qui je suis en contact je suis en train
de communes dans la circonscription que
je représente à semblait national tous
les maires disent qu'aujourd'hui leur
mandat est beaucoup plus difficile à
assumer Cavin pourquoi je crois je pense
qu'il y a la population qui a changé il
y a des exigences qui sont de plus en
plus fortes il y a les réseaux sociaux
qui alimentent le reproche que j'ai à
faire par contre sur ce qui s'est passé
c'est le fait que derrière tout ça il y
avait l'extrême droite c'est des réseaux
sociaux d'extrême droite qui ont opposé
la population
moi-même dans mon village sincère
habitant nous avons un cada un centre
d'accueil de vendeur d'asile ça se passe
très bien ça se passe très bien il y a
une intégration
effectivement il semblerait que les
responsables dernière question
insuffisamment intervenus je suis
incapable de dire si c'est la réalité
moi je sais je sais que chez moi
pour les accompagner c'était peut-être
pas le cas toute dernière question on
parle encore quand même de violence je
voudrais vous faire réagir à cette
tribune de l'historien dans le monde
aujourd'hui qui estime que l'agression
du petit neveu d'Emmanuel Macron
Jean-Baptiste trogneux témoigne d'un
niveau de haine rarement vu contre le
président de la République il dénonce je
le cite la pulsion régicide qui a été
encouragée par certains discours
politique et là il parle notamment des
filles de l'attitude de Thomas porte
Christophe Prudhomme même de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est-ce que ses élus ils sont
responsables pour vous non bien sûr moi
je trouve cette attaque qui a eu lieu
cette agression et inacceptable vraiment
une dégradation terrible en fait des
relations on peut je l'ai dit d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit dans l'hémicycle dit
dans le métier
qui a traité d'assassin Olivier du socle
que certains propos étaient
me faisait honte
on peut avoir des oppositions politiques
on peut avoir un discours politique
extrêmement ferme avec des mots
quelquefois ça m'arrive je suis un peu
sanguin il y a des mots des fois qui qui
peut débordent qui déborde mais pour
autant se faire par le respect je ne
pense pas par contre que
violence ensuite je ne crois pas que ça
puisse bonjour
utiliser
cette ce comportement déplorable qui a
eu lieu cette agression qui a eu lieu en
disant c'est de la faute notamment de la
France insoumise moi je crois que c'est
c'est absolument inacceptable aussi
d'accord merci c'est très clair merci
beaucoup Brigitte et tomtran lui en
rejoint tout de suite Vincent roux en
direct du Figaro live 25 premières
questions d'actualité pour André
Chassaigne est-ce que vous êtes là
Vincent
est-ce que vous êtes là bonjour
Elisabeth voilà vous apparaissez
une bonjour question d'actualité
l'actualité c'est bien sûr la guerre à
l'est de l'Europe en Ukraine
est-ce que selon vous c'est une question
qu'on a posé sur le site du Figaro les
Occidentaux ont raison de fournir des
avions de combat à l'Ukraine
je ne pense pas je suis pour ma part
très très anxieux sur le dérapage que ce
type de fourniture d'avions de combat
quand un champ d'action important que ça
puis que ça peut entraîner et je sais
que les Américains bien sûr ont c'est
quand même curieux d'ailleurs ils ont
dit on lève on lève l'obstacle
c'est-à-dire en autorise on autorise les
les pays d'Europe à fournir des avions
de combat à l'Ukraine en disant
d'ailleurs qu'il en fournira pas
forcément je crois que premièrement
c'est un risque de
d'aggraver le conflit je le pense
véritablement un risque d'aggraver le
conflit et faut être attentif à ça et
aussi d'ailleurs les américains ils vont
en profiter pour si possible placer de
nouveaux avions si les avions qui ont 40
ans à peu près je crois les avions qui
les questions de de donner aux
enseignants mais c'est pas la dernière
génération oui mais c'est des avions qui
ont qui sont très efficaces
effectivement quand ils portaient
importante qui peuvent et qui peuvent
pénétrer
dans sur le territoire russe et le
risque qu'il y a toujours avec ça c'est
qu'il y a un risque de d'amplification
du du conflit
ça vous va Vincent
c'est clair
on reviendra sur l'autre question à la
fin de l'émission et ben voilà très bien
merci beaucoup donc
finalement c'est livraisons d'armes à
répétition et en particulier les avions
de chasse que les Américains ont eu
beaucoup de temps à débloquer pour vous
ça n'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour la
paix je pense que c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour la paix d'ailleurs c'est
très curieux enfin c'est pas curieux
mais ce qui m'interroge beaucoup c'est
que quand on a
quand on aborde la question de la
diplomatie et la question d'une paix
possible on se fait systématiquement
agresser il y a aujourd'hui le discours
qui consiste à dire il faut aussi des
actions diplomatiques je tiens
d'ailleurs a fait le président Macron il
faut le reconnaître ce discours là il y
a un discours qui aujourd'hui est rejeté
de façon façon massive
c'est très compliqué quand on a comme je
le suis euh dans mes tripes quand on a
dans nos tripes un
héritage de d'un parti qui était le
parti d'un parti qui était considéré
comme un parti de la paix quand on a ça
dans l'Autriche et qu'on puisse pas
évoquer la question de la paix ça s'est
produit lors d'une rencontre qui a eu
avec la première ministre où était où
les différents ou les différents
présidents de groupe de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat et était présent
j'ai eu le malheur d'évoquer des
perspectives de P j'ai je me suis fait
ramasser comme étant quelqu'un qui était
un soutien des Russes ce qui était
absolument pas le cas et face à vous
directeur adjoint la rédaction du Figaro
bonsoir bonsoir
je suis content de vous revoir ça fait
longtemps moi aussi alors j'ai peut-être
avoir une première question qui ménage
et moi quand même un peu alors là je
sais pas parce que vous m'avez inspiré
une question mais Staline combien de
morts monsieur je sais bien sûr à partir
de la paix bien sûr
bien sûr qu'il y a eu des millions de
morts avec il y a aussi d'ailleurs eu
des millions de morts dans les rangs de
l'Armée rouge et de la population russe
pour dans la lutte contre le nazisme
n'oublions pas ce qui a été le sacrifice
de la Russie pour abattre le nazisme
parce que l'histoire met de l'eau
écarlate un peu la connais que Staline
n'était pas un grand Pacifique bien sûr
alors je vous écoutais tout à l'heure
avec mes concerts et j'étais
je voudrais aller un peu plus loin sur
les violences si vous me le permettez
vous avez parlé des violences aux élus
est-ce que vous trouvez pas qu'il y a
dans ce pays un climat absolument
délétère que certains qualifient de
pré-insurrectionnel
je répondrai d'ailleurs d'abord
en disant que la violence elle est
jamais d'un seul côté
j'avais lu il y a quelques années je
sais pas dans quel texte c'était Jean
Jaurès qui parlait de la violence qui
était celle des patrons autour du tapis
vert c'était un contexte c'était assez
comparable d'ailleurs à celui qu'on vit
aujourd'hui je dis pas ça pour justifier
un développement de la violence mais je
dis qu'un certain moment comme c'était
le cas d'ailleurs avec la loi sur les
retraites quand on ne tient pas compte
d'un mouvement majoritaire ultra
majoritaire de la population
quand on exprime dans les actes une
forme de mépris effectivement s'alimente
la violence aussi même si on je partage
pas certaines formes de violence ça
alimente la violence je dirais qu'il y a
aussi quelque chose qui est un effet
délétère aujourd'hui ce sont les réseaux
sociaux ça c'est pour moi c'est c'est
quelque chose de terrible à partir des
réseaux sociaux en individus devant son
ordinateur est capable de dire n'importe
quoi on sait pas qu'il dit de de lancer
n'importe quel polémique des des
vraiment longtemps mais c'est vrai que
la violence aujourd'hui
monte et c'est pour cette raison
d'ailleurs que face à ça plutôt que
d'alimenter moi je suis un adepte par
exemple de tout ce qui touche à
l'éducation populaire c'est c'est
discuter avec les gens c'est faire vivre
la vie associative c'est aussi et bien
de montrer une forme une forme
d'optimisme ce sont les joueurs heureux
d'ailleurs dont parle Fabien Roussel
alors justement c'est très intéressant
ce que vous dites là parce que quand on
regarde un peu l'attitude des députés
communistes et des élus communistes et
qu'on regarde l'attitude des députés des
autres formations de la dupesse et
notamment la France insoumise et des
écologistes on voit qu'il y a pas du
tout la même attitude il y a une espèce
de de tradition du dialogue de l'écoute
chez vous c'est pas pour vous flatter
mais et et on voit quand même que on est
dans un mode très vulgaire
d'insultes d'interpellation très souvent
chez les écologistes et chez les la
France insoumise comme nous tolérez ça
je dirais qu'on a une culture
parlementaire les députés communistes
qui est une culture parlementaire
déjà d'être sur le texte essayer de de
pas trop
dévoyés le regard qu'on a sur un texte
qui nous vient de l'exécutif par le
contexte politique c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile donc cette volonté de
d'être utile aussi c'est-à-dire de même
un texte dont on ne partage pas
l'orientation même un texte on ne votera
pas au final et on s'en cache pas si on
peut le faire évoluer pour que ça pour
que ça aille dans le davantage dans le
bon sens ou pour limiter la casse on le
fait ça c'est notre culture qui est
notre culture politique après moi je le
ressens sur ce mandat il y a aussi
tellement de provocations de de la
majorité relative actuelle que ça nous
arrive aussi de d'avoir des mots je l'ai
eu notamment lors de du dernier débat
dans la niche parlementaire où vous avez
deux ministres on a deux ministres qui
ont fait de l'obstruction là je me suis
foutu en colère ce que j'aurais pas fait
peut-être il y a quelques années est-ce
que il y a une feuille de papier à
cigarette qui vous sépare de Monsieur
Roussel et de vos autres des entre vous
les députés communistes maintenant je
crois que on sait qu'il y en a certains
qui aiment la proximité de la France
insoumise et d'autres beaucoup moins
mais on a on a nos personnalités
différentes d'ailleurs le premier je
partage les orientations de Fabien
Roussel mais nous on considère qu'on
peut travailler ensemble avec la France
insoumise et les autres groupes de la
nups travaillent ensemble dans la mesure
où ça répond une atteinte aussi
c'est-à-dire répond quand même une
attente ce qui a eu lieu avait au
dernier aux dernières élections
présidentielles et législatives mais on
tient avoir notre propre parole avoir
nos propres positions et ne pas se faire
avaler par un groupe qui sera un groupe
unique qui serait le groupe de la nups
on tient à notre spécificité à notre
particularité même si on pense que il
est nécessaire assez souvent de
travailler ensemble oui mais alors
Monsieur Roussel dit carrément il faut
penser à l'après Jean-Louis Mélenchon
vous êtes d'accord avec ça bien sûr il
le dit lui ce qu'il dit ce que dit
Fabien c'est fini Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ce que dit en fait le discours que porte
Fabien Roussel c'est se dire que dans la
configuration actuelle de la nups
on sera pas majoritaire et donc il est
nécessaire
d'élargir déjà des relations ont été ce
sont développées entre les quatre
groupes de la Nupe c'est les trois
groupes de gauche du Sénat c'est déjà
une façon d'élargir et de la même façon
en considère que il faut reconstruire
une gauche qui soit plus large que la
nuption aujourd'hui avec un contenu bien
sûr il s'agit pas de retourner à ce qu'a
pu faire la majorité de l'Inde entre
2012 et 2017 mais moi j'ai la conviction
que si on élargit pas la gauche si on ne
s'adresse pas à d'autres forces de
gauche qui aujourd'hui ne se sentent pas
concernés par la nuque je pense qu'on
n'arrivera pas donc l'enjeu il est là si
un jour en fait majorité dans ce pays
faut s'en donner les moyens alors il y a
des élections qui vont arriver l'année
prochaine le Sénat je sais que vous
n'êtes pas candidat contrairement à ce
que donnait la rumeur vous confirmez
solliciter j'avais été sollicitée parce
que avec l'idée que si j'étais candidat
ça pourrait faire gagner
peut-être
je suis un passionné du travail de
l'Assemblée nationale je vais quand même
pas changer de crébrerie pour aller me
perdre dans une autre assemblée alors il
y a des élections européennes c'est ce
que je voulais dire au printemps
prochain au printemps 2024 est-ce que
vous militez pour que vous partiez tous
ensemble à l'intérieur de la nuque tous
les parties de gauche ou au contraire
est-ce que vous voulez que chacun parte
dans son couloir sachant que les si on
regarde bien les sondages les sondages
dit que vous avez intérêt à partir
chacun de votre côté
je sais pas si les sondages ont intérêt
moi je pense qu'on a une ligne qui a été
tracée lors de nos deux derniers congrès
cette ligne je parle du Parti communiste
français bien sûr c'est plutôt de porter
notre parole c'est porter nos
propositions c'est donc
conduire une liste où s'associer une
liste au sein de
pour aller aux élections européennes
mais ça c'est pas encore c'est pas
encore complet une liste communiste oui
il y avait élargi bien sûr à d'autres
partenaires mais on n'est pas pour le
moment pour le moment on n'a pas pris de
décision sur le fait d'avoir une liste
qui serait conduite pour un communiste
ou aller dans une liste avec la France
insoumise donc je veux pas anticiper ce
que sera la discussion du Conseil
national du Parti communiste il a
décision des communistes je crois que ça
ça c'est toujours en débat mais en tout
cas
je n'admets pas
je vais être clair qu'aujourd'hui on
nous montre du doigt qu'on veuille nous
donner une leçon en disant qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça vous voulez pas nous
rejoindre nous prendrons notre décision
en toute noire en toute liberté on n'est
pas des petits garçons que l'on tape
avec une baguette ce que je vois de
toute manière c'est que vous pouvez pas
faire liste de commune avec les
écologistes ou avec le Parti socialiste
qui sont des partis pro-européens alors
que vous êtes un parti beaucoup plus
eurosceptique oui et encore oui on est
on est heureux-sceptique j'aime pas le
mot eurosceptique on n'est pas d'accord
avec les la ligne actuelle très libérale
de l'Union européenne mais moi par
exemple je m'intéresse beaucoup aux
questions européennes CE ne pas dire que
je serais candidat aux élections
européen intentions mais je m'intéresse
beaucoup aux questions européennes au
sein de la commission des affaires
européennes de l'Assemblée nationale
notamment je suis le référent avec une
collègue de la majorité Nicole le paye
je suis référent de la politique
agricole commune je dis moi par exemple
qu'on a besoin d'une politique agricole
commune et je combat même la
renationalisation de l'agriculture
européenne je pense qu'il y a pas tout à
rejeter au niveau de l'Union européenne
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui elle est sur
un fondement extrêmement libéral et nous
on se bat pour la faire évoluer sur sur
une approche qui tienne compte de la
société qui soit qui soit moins la
remorque des groupes de pression des
multinationales mais je ne considère pas
que me réceptique je suis réceptique sur
la politique actuelle l'Union européenne
accordent une dernière question François
Ruffin on a appris qu'il avait ouvert un
compte bancaire pour éventuellement
financer sa campagne électorale en vue
de 2027 est-ce que vous estimez que ça
peut être un bon candidat pour la gauche
réunis François Ruffin en 2027
taper dessus pouvoir porter une
appréciation sur François
personnelle avec lui c'est un
discutablement c'est une vous préférez
peut-être
je vais pas choisir entre Ruffin
Mélenchon c'est pas mon affaire ça c'est
l'affaire de la France insoumise
François Ruffin fait le choix de la
France insoumise c'est à lui de voir
avec la France insoumise si les
candidats ou pas moi aussi là dessus
bien sûr je vais pas prendre parti je
vais pas prendre la présidentielle
mais j'ai quand même pas donné mon avis
sur un candidat potentiel de la France
insoumise malgré toute l'amitié ou
l'estime que je peux avoir pour certains
d'ailleurs vous ne voulez pas que les
autres vous donnent non plus d'avis qui
concerne vos choix donc c'est cohérents
merci beaucoup merci Isabelle merci
c'est dommage malheureusement
on reviendrait avant de d'accueillir
Alexis art dans quelques instants une
question sur une des annonce d'Emmanuel
Macron la semaine dernière mais sur TF1
2 milliards d'impôts en moi pour les
classes moyennes en voilà une bonne
nouvelle alors là quand on m'annonce
deux milliards
d'impôts en moins je me demande je me
demande quels seront les conséquences je
pense au service public je pense à
l'hôpital aux hôpitaux je pense aux
écoles je pense au lycée je pense au
fait que
impôts servent aussi à avoir des
prestations pour la population ne sont
pas trop imposées en France non moi je
dis que peut-être qu'elles sont qu'on
peut revoir notamment une plus grande
progressivité des impôts faire en sorte
nous on avait proposé par exemple qui
est plus de tranches pour imposer
davantage les plus gros revenus on était
recalés par rapport à ça donc on peut
revoir l'échelle de l'impôt mais moi en
ce qui me concerne je suis un défenseur
des impôts que ça soit les impôts locaux
ou les impôts nationaux parce que je
sais que les impôts c'est aussi la
République c'est aussi les services
qu'on offre ensuite
pour moi c'est pas une bonne chose c'est
un effet d'annonce
amidonce parmi d'autres ce manuels
manuel Macron c'est il a des effets
d'annonce comme ça voilà pourquoi parce
qu'il doit se rattraper après
c'est vrai que tous les observateurs
disent que les classe moyenne
aujourd'hui sont celles qui ont beaucoup
trinqués donc c'est aussi sans doute une
par rapport à ça alexisard bonjour à
vous député renaissance de l'Essonne
merci tous les deux d'ailleurs à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté le principe du
débat en face à face dans cette émission
Nicolas hazard votre premier sujet
d'interpellation André Janssen concerne
le dossier de la très important de la
réindustrialisation bien sûr je crois
qu'on sera d'accord tous les deux
là-dessus on a un besoin de
réindustrialiser le pays oui c'est
Alexis Isard
Alexis
aucun problème l'important est de parler
de réindustrialisation depuis deux ans
les résultats sont plutôt bons on a
d'abord réussi à stopper la
désindustrialisation du pays depuis 2017
depuis 2017 pardon et maintenant on voit
la création de nouvelles usines en
France donc on peut s'en réjouir on a de
la chance de voir la création d'emplois
la création d'emplois industriel et je
le rappelle un emploi industriel créé
c'est entre 0 et 8 et 1,5 emplois
indirect qui se créent également donc
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour notre
pays et je pense qu'on sera d'accord sur
ces sujets là d'abord la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on parle enfin
de réindustrialisation c'est vrai que
pendant des années on en parlait pas
nous les comédies on a toujours porté ce
pour tes discours là donc on va pas dire
que de mauvaises choses d'en parler
faut quand même se rappeler qu'il y a
pas si longtemps considéré que c'était
uniquement du tertiaire qu'il fallait
des usines sans salariés pratiquement on
était vers une approche qui consistait à
délocaliser pour faire plus de profits
donc on parle de réalisation c'est une
bonne chose par contre je suis beaucoup
beaucoup moins
optimiste sur les résultats obtenus on
les résultats obtenus ils sont pour le
moment assez limité je crois que les
seuls secteurs qui
qui en fait progresse pour l'essentiel
c'est il y a l'agro il y a l'industrie
agroalimentaire il y a les secteurs des
déchets il y a aussi l'eau mais le reste
c'est quand même extrêmement timide il y
a très peu très peu de progrès qui ont
été faits et notamment sur la des
relocalisations puisqu'on a beaucoup
parlé avec la crise du covid de
relocalisation je lisais il y a pas
longtemps que il y a une cinquantaine
d'entreprises seulement qui ont
relocalisé qui auront représenté
ensemble 800 emplois avec une moyenne
donc de 16 emplois par entreprise et je
pense que pour le moment la grande
priorité devrait être localisation
France qui a eu il y a quelques jours
c'est plusieurs c'est 13 milliards
d'euros qui sont qui vont être investis
pour réindustrialiser c'est on est pour
la quatrième année de suite le pays dans
lequel les investisseurs étrangers en
Europe investissent le plus c'est une
bonne nouvelle on voit arriver beaucoup
d'industriels qui viennent créer des
usines de batterie dans le Nord ce qui
est très positif là-dedans c'est que les
industries reviennent dans les
territoires qui avaient été désertés et
dans lesquelles on voyait le chômage
énormément monté ils vont revenir ils
vont créer de l'emploi qualifié parce
que vous le parliez du tertiaire tout à
l'heure vous avez totalement raison un
emploi industriel il paye bien mieux
qu'un emploi du tertiaire aujourd'hui et
ça il faut qu'on arrive à le remettre
dans des jeunes et qu'on recrée cette
vocation d'industrie j'aurais préféré en
ce concernait réindustrialisation une
approche différente le sentiment que ça
me donne c'est qu'il y a j'ai utilisé un
peu une image on fait un peu la danse du
ventre quoi pour attirer des entreprises
ces entreprises en les attire avec bien
sûr des avantages extrêmement importants
au niveau fiscalité on les on les attire
avec des avantages que donc qui leur
sont accordés au niveau fiscal avec des
aides aussi d'ailleurs avec des aides
financières donc mais ces entreprises on
a il y a pas vis-à-vis d'elle on n'a pas
d’accord dans la durée et on a connu
dans le passé des entreprises qui
profitent qui profitent des faits
d'aubaine et qui en définitive ne
restent pas donc je suis un peu même si
on peut se réjouir comme des créations
d'emploi je n’ai pas une optimisme bien
et d'autant plus que souvent ce sont des
ce sont des entreprises qui vont venir
chez nous qui vont d'ailleurs aussi
peut-être englobé ça a été le cas déjà
elles sont prises américaines qui qui
englobe qui avalent des entreprises
françaises qui en même temps partent
avec les brevets on a pu la voir donc
faut être très attentif par rapport à ça
et je préférerais moins avoir une note
des marches qui serait une démarche plus
organisée territoriale
et pour la restauration
je pense que derrière tout ça alors je
crois que c'est faux vous le faites avec
enthousiasme je crois que c'est faux
pour deux raisons la première
je comprends et je suis persuadé que
vous êtes convaincu de ce que vous dites
mais je crois que derrière tout ça il y
a beaucoup de il y a quand même pas mal
de mousse
je ne suis pas d'accord pour deux
raisons d'abord la première étant que
ici on parle de réindustrialisation et
pas de capitaux je suis d'accord avec
vous quand les capitaux étrangers
arrivent dans les entreprises de
services on peut avoir peur qu'après les
compétences et qu'elles s'en aille ici
elles vont créer des usines elles vont
construire des usines du matériel qui va
être en quelque sorte ancré dans les
territoires et deuxièmement je vais vous
dire une deuxième chose c'est que si les
usines aussi les entreprises
réinvestissent en France c'est parce que
ce qu'on leur promet dans le projet de
loin industrie verte c'est pas plus
d'avantages fiscaux c'est une
simplification de l'arrivée en France
c'est une simplification c'est pas plus
simplifier que la terre entière c'est se
mettre au niveau de nos voisins c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il fasse pas on n'est
pas besoin de 18 mois pour créer une
usine en France mais plus que 9 mois
c'est deux choses exactement ce qui se
passe en Allemagne c'est de se mettre au
niveau de nos voisins européens deux
choses par rapport à ça moi j'ai
rapidement regardé la nouvelle la loi
sur le projet de loi sur l'industrie
vert d'abord sur les entreprises qui
viennent très souvent ce sont des
entreprises d'assemblage et qui vont
impliquer des importations de pays qui
produisent à bas coût et j'aurais
préféré que il y ait une stratégie qui
consiste à voir des entreprises qui
créent plus de valeur en quelque sorte
avec avec une forme de avec une forme de
planification dans la durée il y a
justement cette nouvelle création de
valeur sur notre territoire j'aurais
préféré qu'il y ait une planification
dans la durée on n'a pas assez de
planification là qui avait été
la même manière que sur les projets de
nucléaires qu'on a fait la loi c'est
celle de l'ENR en fait l'idée c'est que
sur les projets d'intérêt nationaux
c'est la même chose pour les industries
nucléaires et de NR le préfet puisse
dire bah là il y a une nécessité ça va
dans le sens de la planification que
vous demandez de dire sur notre
territoire on a besoin de cette
technologie ça pourrait être le cas dans
le Nord où on a besoin d'usine de
batterie par exemple mais vous de dire
on a besoin de cette
réponse est après une question sur euh
je pense qu'il faut quand même qu'on ait
confiance en nos élus locaux et il
assassin des maires de France a émis de
fortes réserves par rapport à ça en
estimant que les élus ont cette volonté
bien sûr d'attirer des entreprises y
compris des entreprises vertes comme on
dit et qu'il faut être attentif à ce que
il y ait pas une volonté de l'État qui
ne respecte pas les choix qui sont les
choix des collectivités territoriales
moi je suis socialement parce que les
Français d'ailleurs sont très attachés à
ce sujet toute dernière question
j'ai commentaire là-dessus c'est de dire
que tous les projets d'industrie sur les
territoires ne seront pas soumis à la
main du préfet les élus locaux garderont
la main ce sera simplement pour les
projets d'intérêt nationaux
notamment sur les friches ça c'est
intéressant tout à fait oui sur la
réforme finalement qui va qui va en lien
avec ce projet de réindustrialisation
parce qu'on a besoin de compétences on a
besoin de créer des compétences et on
remarque que dans le lycée professionnel
on a un taux de décrochage au lycée
professionnel on a un taux de décrochage
à peu près trois fois supérieur au lycée
classique on a tendance à y emmener des
élèves par défaut alors qu'on a besoin
de créer des vocations je le disais tout
à l'heure un métier industriel c'est 10
à 15 fois plus rémunéré avec des
capacités d'évolution au sein de
l'entreprise et ça il faut donner envie
d'industrie c'est très forme moi je la
trouve catastrophique je la trouve je
prends un exemple vous avez un jeune qui
est dans un bac pro actuellement durant
les trois années de bac pro il aura je
crois 22 semaines de stage en entreprise
là le projet de loi va faire en sorte
qu'il aura le double il aura 44 semaines
alors c'est à peu près attendez
laissez-moi expliquer il y aura à peu
près le double de stage en entreprise or
le risque pour Macaigne norme c'est
qu'on sacrifie les formations de base et
conforme des salariés qui soit des
salariés sur un seul métier alors
qu'aujourd'hui un jeune qui va rentrer
dans la vie active il faut savoir qu'il
aura à faire cette dix métiers
différents peut-être que dans les 15 ans
qui suivent 50% des métiers auront
disparu il y en aura d'autres et je
pense
20 ans après une formation ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on va mettre les
jeunes dans une forme d'entonnoir et on
va les former pour un métier déterminé
parce qu'il y a des métiers sous tension
au moins ce que je considère c'est qu'un
jaune un jeune il soit capable durant
toute sa vie active de pouvoir évoluer
ça sera pas le cas ça sera pas le guider
de la réforme c'est pas ça l'idée de la
réforme c'est de dire que durant la
première et la deuxième année
ça ne change réellement si ce n'est que
les semaines de stage sont rémunérés en
seconde 50 euros par semaine payer par
première 60 cahiers payés par l'État en
sorte que les entreprises continuent que
les entreprises continuent à les prendre
et lors de la terminale là il y aura
deux choix qui s'ouvriront c'est soit
l'élève veut continuer ses études aller
vers un BTS et dans ce cas-là il y aura
plus d'heures de formation
spécialiser dans un métier donc il y
aura plus de de stage en entreprise
l'idée étant d'être plus à la carte et
de faire profiter durant les temps de
formation à l'école aux jeunes du
formation plus qualifié en petit groupe
pour faire en sorte sur les fondamentaux
un jeune qui est en troisième année donc
un terminal de bac pro si on lui propose
d'aller faire je sais pas deux mois ou
trois mois de stage en entreprise où il
touchera je crois ça sera 100 euros s'il
est en terminale sera 100 euros par
semaine 100 euros par semaine le jeune
puisqu'ils sont pour l'essentiel issu de
mieux modeste tous les chiffres
beaucoup beaucoup toutes les
statistiques montent se sont
essentiellement des jeunes
issus milieu modestes ils iront sur
cette voie-là ils iront sur cette loi
sur cette voie et ils seront dans un
entonnoir sur un métier et au lieu de
continuer leurs études et ensuite de
progresser dans leur vie
quand même que dénoncentrer peut-être
que vous pouvez améliorer la sensible
parce que bien au contraire c'est soit
ils choisira de faire une durée plus
longue de stage et dans ce cas là il
sera employable très vite la mesure est
de faire en sorte qu'ils sont appelés
soit ils choisira de faire un peu moins
employable pour un métier de faire un
peu moins de stage pour ensuite faire un
BTS qui fera en alternance
je lisais aussi des une étude par
rapport à ça il y a à peu près il a
grande majorité des entreprises ne font
pas des formations pour faire évoluer le
salarié quand on a un pays comme
l'Allemagne d'ailleurs quand on a pris
comme ce que je veux dire que on peut
évoluer en étant sur le tas en étant à
son tour
s'il a pas eu les enseignements
fondamentaux qui sont donnés moi je
pense que ce projet de loi je pense que
ce projet de loi catastrophique je le
dis pour moi ce projet de loi c'est une
erreur du projet de loi et justement de
renforcer les fondamentaux en faisant
des petits groupes et je peux rappeler
aussi que même si rien n'est parfait
dans l'éducation n'est quand même la
première année ou après 15 ans de déclin
dans le niveau scolaire en primaire on
est la première année où ça se stabilise
alors c'est pas c'est pas les merveilles
c'est pas exceptionnel mais en tout cas
on voit que on a stoppé la dégradation
du niveau qui était en marge depuis 15
ans donc ça on peut s'en féliciter
maintenant il faut qu'on renforcement et
pourtant j'étais moi-même principal de
collèges j'ai deux filles qui sont dans
l'éducation nationale dans une qui est
le professeur des écoles et ben ça ça
met pas remonté les constats qui sont
faits sur le terrain ne correspondent
pas toujours tout à fait c'est constat
là
merci infiniment d'avoir été là et
d'avoir animé ce débat restez encore
quelques instants avec lui
c'est toujours très agréable d'avoir de
parlementaires qui débattent avec
intelligence Vincent roux est-ce que
vous êtes là Vincent auront une autre
question il va préparer sa deuxième
question
allez-y Vincent
j'essaye de la poser avec intelligence
euh justement au Parlement en ce moment
on discute d'un projet de loi important
qui est la loi de programmation
militaire est-ce que vous la voterez en
l'état André Chassaigne
bon la décision du vote que l'on émettra
n'a pas corps été prise mais je doute
quand la vote en l'état je suis même
certain que si elle reste en l'état on
la votera pas tout simplement parce
qu'il y a un parti pris qui a notre avis
est fait d'une armée qui est une armée
de projection de projection sur des
conflits certes qui peuvent se dérouler
sur la planète avec des choix je prends
l'exemple du porte-avion on voit bien
que ça c'est un parti pris d'une armée
qui est une armée de projection pour des
conflits qui pourraient avoir lieu par
exemple dans le Pacifique ou ailleurs
nous on est très attaché à une armée qui
soit une armée de défense du territoire
or les choix qui sont faits au niveau
budgétaire avec quand même une
augmentation je crois de 40% de la
programmation de la militaire par
rapport à la programmation précédente
les choix qui sont faits
pour l'essentiel auront des conséquences
négatives et on va abandonner par
exemple
je prends l'exemple des frégates qui qui
que la marine attendait et Ben qui ont
été qui vont être limités en production
il y avait en ne respectera pas ce qu'il
y avait annoncé il y a des il y a des
matériels militaires comme des tanks par
exemple des chars dans un goût
c'est-à-dire que je pense qu'on met le
on met une priorité à mon avis trop
forte sur une armée qui est énervée de
projection plutôt que d'avoir une armée
de défense du territoire c'est l'analyse
que l'on fait
Vincent il y a pas assez d'équipements
mais vous avez de ce point de vue là le
même point de vue que les députés LR
je sais pas quel est le point de vue des
députés
lors du moment d'après ces dents à la
Commission de la Défense j'ai fait deux
rapports j'ai fait un rapport sur
l'équipement du soldat où on voit que
par exemple il y a beaucoup beaucoup à
faire et je ne suis pas sûr que dans la
programmation militaire on aille très
loin là-dessus et deuxièmement sur des
équipements que je vais les citer un
exemple complet comme un rapport que
j'ai fait sur sur les risques nucléaires
radiologique biologique et chimique où
on a au niveau on a aujourd'hui
insuffisamment d'équipements au cas où
on a une attaque de Jarre et je pense
que ça c'est qu'on met beaucoup d'argent
pour la dissuasion nucléaire et on met
beaucoup d'argent sur une armée de
projection merci beaucoup Vincent à la
semaine prochaine non d'ailleurs pas la
semaine prochaine la semaine d'après
merci encore André chassaine j'aurais
voulu vous parler du projet de loi pas
le projet de loi avait propositions de
LR sur l'immigration mais ce sera pour
une prochaine fois c'est dommage
en un mot en un mot c'est ce que c'est
bienvenu
quand on voit qu'ils ils envisagent un
référendum pour par exemple ne respecte
pas ce qui peut se faire au niveau
européen je crois que c'est un peu
n'importe quoi de proposer chaque chose
voilà c'est n'importe quoi c'est votre
dernier mot mais c'est une appréciation
provisoire sur ses propositions du
groupe LR assemblée Sénat sur
l'immigration merci à tous les deux
merci particulièrement réchauffer
d'avoir passé l'heure avec nous dans
auditions publiques sur LCP Public Sénat
on se retrouve dans 15 jours bien sûr à
19h30 bonne soirée merci